Jamie's starting off this hour in
Missouri hey Jamie how are you hi I'm
good how are you
better than I deserve what's up thanks
for taking my call
so I have a question it might sound like
a small facility session to somebody but
that seems like a lot of money to us so
I wanted to ask you about it we're about
seventy thousand dollars in student loan
debts right now we've been trying to
kind of work through the second baby
steps so we've been throwing everything
we've got towards the loan and as of
recently I I feel like I need an cell
phone where you're going to put 350
bucks to buy a new phone and I know that
that seems like a lot of money to us
just to put down on the cell phone but I
feel like I have legit reasons why I
think I need to get a new one we have a
lot of like changes coming up in our
lives recently I just wanted to get your
input on that and guess 350 down just to
pay a cellphone know like the full price
I guess
well that bars on it recently to buy it
I'm sure what's your household into so
I'm the only one working right now and I
make 45 to 50 thousand a year pre-tax
that's what overtime and your husband
doesn't work why it was currently
finishing up PA school he had a job who
heard that Walmart was like shelving me
honey when will he be finished with PA
school um he graduates in December about
a week before we have a first baby the
reason a question like yours is
important is not because $350 is
important in the scope of your life it's
because you you're making a judgment
call here on what you're focusing on and
what you value and that's why it's
important and if you're if you're
focusing on finishing PA school so that
his income comes up and we're trying to
get out of debt and I've rationalized
the purchase of something that I
shouldn't be purchasing that's a bad
thing if we're buying something that is
a necessity
that's a that's a certainly an okay
thing we do want you to buy food and we
do want you to keep the lights on and so
why is it an upgrade in cellphone is a
necessity and not just a want so I've
had I mean what kind of crazy but I've
had my phone for almost seven years now
so what does your phone work it does
work so why isn't overrated necessity so
why isn't upgrade a necessity because I
want to take pictures of her baby when
he was born and my phone I have a camera
and his doesn't it's even worse honestly
I is not a stupid reason but I just want
to have good pictures so it's a
rationalization you don't use a cell
phone for a camera when cameras are
cheaper if that's the only reason you're
buying it okay they'll get you a cheap
camera they'll get you a little digital
camera and take lots of pictures of jr.
for 50 bucks
I mean digital camera yeah I mean it's
that camera is about 10 years old and
the camera on your phone takes pictures
too right okay so you have two ways to
take pictures of the baby you do what
you want to do you call me and ask me
this questions I'll give you an answer
you have rationalized an upgrade on the
emotion of your child and as an exercise
of your value system that's something
you need to break this is a test are you
going to pass the test because the the
description you've given me of why you
want to do this is and is definitely a
luxury it's definitely a want
there's no one's life in danger it's not
a necessity of this household you have
the ability to take pictures of your
child they're not gonna be damaged and
then counseling when they're thirty
because there's no childhood pictures of
them you just want the upgraded phone
and you figured out a way to blame it on
your baby and you've got to stop that
kind of decision-making process that's
why it's an important question and so I
appreciate you asking it
I had to do this too kiddo I mean I
wasn't exactly the same thing I'm the
guy that used to think when I went into
Costco or Sam's that the reason they
checked your receipt on the way out was
I thought it was federal law you had to
spend $200 I'm a spender by nature I can
rationalize my butt off on something
that I just went and one of the benefits
of me going broke was that got fried out
of me not to the point that I'm so
frugal now I can't breathe I actually
still have that spender gene inside of
me and I actually do enjoy buying some
nice things now I can afford them but I
had to reach this point in my spiritual
growth and my emotional maturity that I
did not use a false decision-making
paradigm to make a purchase and when I
got past that then I enjoyed the
purchases that much more rather than
back when I used to just go oh well if
we don't do this it's just a one-time
thing and if you pass up on the one time
I've got all the rationalizations down I
used to use all of them and it got me in
trouble and so on you know one of the
things that you do is you transform your
heart while you're transforming your
finances and this is a test don't flunk
this test because the next test will be
a minivan and it'll be thirty five
thousand not three hundred fifty dollars
there'll be another test following this
if you flunk it you get to take the test
over that's how tests work and so it's
an important question although it sounds
trivial and you were a little bit afraid
it was trivial it's a hard question and
you're you're creating a new muscle in
your heart the way you make decisions
when you pass this test so that's it's a
very important test
we all have flunked this test in America
at times Congress flunk this test every
day and it causes overspending with
rationalization and it's hard it's hard
and I'm not gonna make fun of your pick
on you because of the triviality of your
of your question because down inside of
that question is a very important
question it's a very important test